do you think his work
can have its effect without the analytic
process
there is the idea floating around that
analysis is a
form that might end it's it's something
that grew up in the 19th 20th century
and it might
might not go on as a way of doing things
the analytic
process itself i don't believe that
if one takes the analytic process a
certain young pupils take it as a whole
technique and an encounter with
a certain payment regulations and
all these technicalities transference
counter transfers
that that's all nonsense but that was
never what you meant
for for young analysis was a spontaneous
encounter of two human beings
and i think that will always happen
because you see
you look in the far east the real wisdom
has always been transmitted
from master to pupil that means hours
from human being to single human being
it's the only way to really transmit
something
but there's usually a container of some
kind a form
that holds you together i think that
will just vary
it will just be different yeah
i don't know what form it might take or
not take i mean
and then certainly many of the ideas
jung expressed are
what one would call in the air and
people find them
independently of not without knowing
your reading
they by looking into themselves come to
the same conclusions
so to my idea there are thousands of
unions in the whole world who have never
heard the word
jung but to me they are jungians because
they are based on the same experience
and the same inner truth they give you
different names
and that doesn't matter you you can't
really say that young's work represents
just science or science in the old
sense or that it's it's not a religion
and yet
what is it itself the work that he did
doesn't it somewhere live on the border
between those
it's certainly beyond science if you
take science in the center of the 19th
century
it's not a hard science it's partly a
hard science i mean
the the doc doctrine let's call it or
the hypothesis of the archetype
and these things you can really prove
with hard science with hard research
with hard research and you can anybody
put it under everybody's nose and you
can make experiments
with it and so on so there's a bit of
hard science in it
then there is an art because analysis is
an
art is a skill it depends on the
personality on the spontaneity of the
personality
i would say that's much more something
artistic or
generally human
and then you can say it if you want the
definition i would say the closest twist
is something like
the original taoism in china
a kind of wisdom
not the taoism later became schools and
you know techniques but india
i would say and trunks and so such
people
that was a wisdom which has infinitely
influenced
china without having definite techniques
and i see union psychology more parallel
to that a bit
that's why it's not a it's not a
religion
and it's not a science
if you want the word i mean i don't like
words but if you want to pin the word on
it i would say
a kind of wisdom